so donald trump actually granted a
post-election interview
now that the supreme court rejected
hearing
another bogus lawsuit about so-called
voter fraud
this wasn't a real interview in the
sense that trump would be asked
actual questions and put in a position
to defend his claims with facts
it wasn't an interview in that sense it
was actually the opposite it was an
interview where donald trump was given
the repeated opportunity to make claims
not based in reality
without being challenged on anything and
the interviewer is brian kilmeade from
fox news
despite claims that fox news has gone
liberal now by newsmax and oan
brian kilmeade was there to ensure that
no one for a second
could think fox news remains anything
but a right-wing propaganda channel
and to be clear there are countries
where if you do an interview like this
while claiming to be a reporter or
journalist you would be publicly
ostracized and you might even have to
resign from your job because you would
be so ashamed
publicly shamed for doing an interview
like this in the united states at fox
news
i guess you sort of get an atta boy for
doing an interview like this
in fact brian kilmeade helped trump
spread the lies
in this first clip brian kilmeade echoes
the lie that donald trump has previously
told
which is when barack obama left office
and trump took over the military had no
ammunition
they had no bullets the cupboards were
bare which could not be more of a brazen
lie
take a look everything you accomplished
you took over a military
that was cut by 25 yeah that only had
three brigades ready to fight and was
out of bullets
what have you done in the four years
since you to change that
entirely rebuilt military like never
before
new missiles and rockets and tanks and
ships and planes and we have
the f-35s coming in by the hundreds as
you know
when i took over we had a depleted
military we had no ammunition i'll never
forget a
very overrated general coming to see me
and saying sir we have no ammunition i'm
sorry this is my first
two days in office right and i say no
president should ever have to hear that
and no president should ever be spied on
either you know
so we we set a lot of records but uh
we have a totally rebuilt and our
nuclear is now tippy top and just hope
to god you never have to use it today
the idea that our military was out of
bullets
is so absurd that it's hilarious if you
understand the stranglehold that the
military-industrial complex
has over our country and government and
economy including both democrats and
republicans
it's a laughable claim trump by the way
also slipping in the lie that obama
spied on his campaign which at this
point is a comedy
you know it's it's a comedy meme outside
of trump world
trump then went on to revive another
completely
bonkers notion that he previously
tweeted about which is that
listen if you need proof that i really
won this thing
election night the bookies had me
winning the election
and so clearly joe biden must have
stolen it this actually has to be seen
to be believed but
in a sense it's logical casino guy trump
says look at the bookies for proof that
this was stolen
the election was over at 10 o'clock in
the evening i had one it was 97
98 percent all of the bookies all over
the world were saying the election's
over they wouldn't even take bets on it
and then all of a sudden around 11
o'clock ballots start getting dropped
you ever see the graph where you go like
this and then it goes up to the sky
tens of thousands of ballots were being
illegally dropped
the machines are the worst dominion
dominion nobody even knows who owns it
these machines are controlling our
country so it was a rigged election it
was a
it was a really a sham and a shame when
you uh
at least now he's calling them massive
ballot drops
rather than massive dumps but what he's
saying
is not any more logical he lost the
election plain and simple
now this next clip is amazing because
it's the height of projection
trump says he's worried he's worried
guys
trump is worried that having an
illegitimate president would be bad for
the country
now now when trump says illegitimate
president he means joe biden but of
course
joe biden won so it's trump who would be
the illegitimate president if he
somehow figured out a way to stay in
power when you when you look at this
fight though you have 77 of trump
supporters who believe you won the
election according to a fox player
i've heard actually much higher numbers
there's a there's a rally right now in
washington
for that do you worry about the country
being divided as if it goes to
inauguration and they still feel that
way and you still feel that way no i
worry about the country having an
illegitimate president that's what i
worry about
a president that lost and lost badly
this wasn't like a close election
you look at georgia we won georgia big
we won pennsylvania big
uh we won wisconsin big we want it big
but you're going to want all of these
stuff do you think your legal team has
proven that well we don't we never get a
chance to prove it because a judge will
say well i'm sorry you don't have
standing
like how about me texas and all of these
states
18 or 19 altogether they come in think
how nice that is where they actually
come in
and they say we want to support you sir
because you're important to this country
we want to support you
they go in and they say the states don't
have sanding and i don't have i'm
president of the united states i just
got 75 million votes
the biggest number of votes in the
history of our country ever gotten by a
sitting president
by the way let's not forget the absolute
travesty
of brian kilmeade setting up these
softball
questions for trump a true journalistic
perversion he should be ashamed of
himself
but trump continues to just be unable to
be parodied because what he says is so
ridiculous he's worried we might have an
illegitimate president yeah i am too
we just disagree about who that would be
i think the guy who won
would be the legitimate president trump
thinks the guy who won
would be illegitimate in that it's joe
biden in his mind
now this next one is interesting brian
kilmeade
actually asks trump who rigged the
election
now if we actually that that that's like
question
one point if you first ask what do you
think of the results and trump says they
were rigged against me
the first logical journalistic follow-up
is who rigged it
and how and it starts to get a little
more interesting i didn't lose
the election was rigged by who by the
democrats and actually
interesting by the democrats but by
local democrats meaning state democrats
they outsmarted state republicans you
know what i do i do two things
i run a country and we cut taxes and we
did all of the things regulations
space force so that's trump continuing
to throw the state republicans under the
bus now of course
a real journalist if brian kilmeade were
one would have had
a dozen follow-up questions based on
this he didn't but it's interesting to
see trump
throw state republicans under the bus
because that's code for people
like georgia governor brian kemp who was
unwilling to do illegal maneuvering to
try to steal this election for donald
trump and that's very interesting
because
it's not praise of brian kemp in any
real way brian
remember brian kemp is a disgusting and
depraved guy
but the point is when even brian kemp is
unwilling to help a republican
it's because what trump is asking for is
that absurd
and by the way brian kemp i'm guessing
probably realizes no matter what he does
even if he were able to overturn georgia
joe biden still win so why would he do
it
this last one is genius trump says that
they i i guess meaning biden democrats
his opponents
they are winning on technicalities like
the supreme court saying texas doesn't
have standing to bring the lawsuit which
we're going to talk about in a moment no
judge has had the courage including the
supreme court i am so disappointed
in them no judge including the supreme
court of the united states
has had the courage to allow it to be
heard the supreme court all they did is
say we don't have standing
so he they're saying essentially that
the president of the united states and
texas
and these other states great states they
don't have standing
they didn't go into the evidence if you
would look at the evidence
thousands of pages of evidence we have
over a thousand
affidavits from people so trump again
mentions affidavits which are neither
here nor there and when we looked at the
affidavits they actually read like
comedy scripts
but the issue of standing is an
important one the supreme court did
decide
did say texas does not have standing to
challenge
the results in these four states now in
law
standing means you can demonstrate to
the court
that you're connected to the harm
from the action that is being challenged
or from the law that is being challenged
and that supports you being in the case
so if i want to bring a lawsuit
i have to have some kind of standing
some connection to
i'm being affected in some way or or
whatever the case may be
for texas to have standing and suing
over the results in georgia pennsylvania
whatever
you would have to say and this is i
think roughly the argument they made
well if the georgia and wisconsin and
pennsylvania if those
elections were fraudulent it essentially
devalues
the election we held in texas it makes
our election not matter it
disenfranchises texas
if other elections are fraudulent as
they claim
it's very very loose and supreme court
said no
so it's not a technicality it's it's
sort of a fundamental issue
when it comes to one's ability to bring
complaints to courts
and then absolutely last clip and then
we're going to move on
donald trump was asked given that the
supreme court did this
is it all over and trump says no we're
going to keep going
i found out late last night that the
supreme court would not hear
the texas case it did not have standing
according to them
i so judged by judging by your tweets
you're very uh very disappointed in that
is it over no it's not over we keep
going and we're going to continue to go
forward we have numerous local cases
where
you know in some of the states that got
now what are the next stages of keeping
going
i don't know so an absolutely disgusting
interview another one in the books for
donald trump there are fewer remaining
sort of be pleased by that at least with
trump as president
later today we'll talk about the
electoral vote certification that's
happening
and big announcement january 1st 2021
okay first day of the new year
we are going to be doing a january 1
2021 membership special the likes of
which this country has never seen
now because these these discounts that
we do are so
huge they may be illegal under a biden
administration so before biden comes in
and says no more discounts that are this
big
we are doing a january 1 single day
membership drive
i would really encourage you to
participate in this to be notified
just get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com very very easy get on
our newsletter
january 1 you'll get an email saying
here's how you sign up an amazing
amazing day it's going to be
and last absolutely last thing uh
follow the david pakman show on
instagram where you have
the ability to see even more clips of
the show
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a massive
holiday sale on all of their products
right now and you can take advantage of
it by going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you
or a gift for someone else vincero is a
brand that has a serious dedication to
the craft of watchmaking which is really
evident when you look closely at their
watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wristwatch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over 25 000
five star reviews because you won't find
a better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video